and if we look at the ratio of the
amount of people that got sick and then
the amount of people that died that
ratio will tell you that China's numbers
are not only false but they're really
false I would like to begin by
announcing some important developments
in a war against the Chinese virus notes
from the US president's press conference
showing the word Corona crossed out and
replaced with Chinese I think attacked
China to divert the public's attention
from their own incompetence to control
the Barrows I think the US government
has not been focusing saving people's
lives we know there are many conspiracy
theories out there conspiring to erode
public trust I can tell you that there
is a significant amount of evidence that
this came from that laboratory in one
this tweet from a Chinese government
spokesperson claiming that the u.s. army
brought the virus to Wuhan my current
view of the US government overall is
negative based on poor leadership lack
of transparency and what I think is a
really flawed justice and electoral
system I've really let down to see what
China became because it had a lot of
potential to be something great and Xi
Jinping came in and squandered it
squandered it
China has likely to come out of this any
stronger position than the u.s. is
likely to come out of this in a weaker
position this may drive the US and China
more deeply into a new Cold War
[Music]
my name is Eva I'm 25 years old I lived
in Beijing right now but I just came
back from the United States and I'm my
own producer hi my name is each I live
in Beijing now I'm 30 year old I'm a
conference interpreter my name is Jehan
I live in Shanghai I I'm doing research
in machine learning
my name is Melanie I am 30 years old I
live in South Florida and I'm a
glassblower hi I'm Eric 33 I live in Los
Angeles California and I'm an executive
assistant at a production company I'm
Lola you can call me Lola I'm a
bilingual event TV host but since this
pandemic I do a lot of interpreting to
help support myself
my country has done a good job
responding to the pandemic and if you
disagree you can turn off your camera
I actually just came back from the
United States in March cuz I just
finished my graduate studies there so
and when I was there I was I have to
like quarantine at home and not be able
to like attend class like in person and
now I'm back I start my new life in
Beijing and everything is great is back
to normal like shops are open like malls
open and yeah people have to wear a mask
but considering what happened in China
like month ago so I think overall it's
being Reagan like the government has
done a great job of course we had a
really hard time in the past few months
but at least we see hopes as long as we
don't have a second way so life should
be go on like no more for the future my
hometown only has seven people in toto
impacted but the whole whole whole city
was also locked down so quickly you know
nothing happens basically beside wearing
a mask
nothing cannot like it's different to me
can they disagree Oz please join the
conversation
so the only thing I would ask you guys
in analyzing whether or not your
government did a good job of handling
the coronavirus I'm not saying they did
a bad job but I am saying that we don't
really know if they did a good or bad
job or not you know China still has a
huge chunk of its population that are
old and they don't understand the
concept of germs and washing your hands
and all this not to mention in Chinese
public toilets you don't have hand soap
so the idea that between three and four
thousand people only that number died
from coronavirus obviously is completely
false yes we have a lot of old people
who are not that educated but they have
they have kids and we don't let them to
go out and also you know because there's
a force up the whole lockdown and but my
question though is not after the fact
that when they announced that the thing
was a pandemic I'm talking about in
December I'm talking about
Leigh Whannell when he was I mean when
he was getting depressed during that
time the virus is spreading throughout
the entire country and throughout the
world all the pandemic into follows this
curve and you can look at all the data
how it has to follow this because this
is how you spread so you know matching
all the data that we have at the end now
we have in the middle and when people
spread so all those data are public and
the science scientists can recover how
they spread through models and this all
are consistent because the scientists
are obscured of your government the Kuna
don't say Shan town the Choshu Thai yeah
well we can't die yeah other Siamese
from other country to draw comparisons
with other countries like for example
Italy that might also have poor hygienic
standards that also might be a condensed
population and if we look at the ratio
of the amount of people that got sick
and then the amount of people that died
that ratio will tell you that China's
numbers are not only false but they're
really false as interpreter I always
questioned that the Chinese government's
number because on daily basis
I'm hearing those numbers and I'm
hearing the challenge of those foreign
experts about Chinese numbers as
individuals we don't have the ways to
verify the numbers
no one can but I think there's something
that you cannot lie about you cannot
just hide those patients sorry once
they're infected they have to stay there
until they recovered so how do I know
about things are getting better in
Beijing I actually had a surgery back in
December and then my doctor called me
saying that you cannot come back to the
hospital we're not opening so now I got
a phone call about in March saying that
oh okay it's time to go now and though
so because I actually went to Shanghai
and Wuhan for the same problem I have so
they also gave me the same call saying
that now we're opening business again
there's one thing we're sure that things
in China are slowly getting under
control I just wanted to say a couple of
things first of all I don't believe it's
not a good job but for very different
reasons than the ones that you guys are
talking about illnesses that have been
contagious that have gone out there that
we didn't lock down over and didn't
cause any more damage than this I really
believe that the harm that was done
because of the shutdown which in America
we only had a very small amount of hot
spots so it wasn't that bad but then we
have people killing themselves because
they can't support their families
anymore it's been developed yeah and
yeah exactly it's ruining lives when
there's really no evidence to say that
the lockdown did anything to help and
also there's doctors who are speaking
out that aren't being given platforms
because they're not saying what the
mainstream media wants them to be saying
and they're saying that lock guns don't
do anything China lied people died
I mean China live in the beginning of it
when they said everything was fine and
over and over again they said everything
was fine so certainly people died during
that period that didn't need to die
things did not look good going into this
pandemic for Xi Jinping it's really
likely that he tried to suppress it
tried tried realized it wasn't possible
said [ __ ] it let it go to the rest of
the world let it become a global problem
this way I won't be the victim of
domestic criticism but the thing is
that's a problem
America had a pandemic response team we
had that okay Obama left that in office
and guess what Trump got rid of it so if
you're asking me like I think the reason
that this virus spread around the world
is definitely on the Chinese government
specifically Xi Jinping but the fact
that so many Americans have died and
it's been so devastating to America I
think that's Donald Donald J Trump the
reality is it's true in sort of that I
do believe that a certain amount of
suppression and and lying or whatever
you know definitely allowed the thing to
grow but then to somehow put all of that
on that single sort of central component
feels like a massive oversimplification
and frankly in my opinion just a
political ploy to to remove any sort of
blame or any sort of responsibility in
like their response well I agree with
sustain in the same way I agree that
when Donald Trump lies American lives
are lost the same back in December at
the end of December I actually receive a
message from my high school classmate
who is now doing a PhD in biology in the
States he warned us like our classmates
about that there's unknown virus going
on in Wuhan and we all panic a little
bit because it was stars like but later
on we saw on a new CCTV denouncing this
rumor and then I was okay probably
nothing and then went out my life
traveling and I know many people include
my clients will make total different
decision if they knew earlier I have a
client who travel to Han one day before
the lockdown and he was trapped there
and she'll recently so definitely many
lives are lost because the Chinese women
life covered up in denial and silencing
the doctor that's for sure but I agree
with Eric that saying that China is
responsible for all the body counts this
is just unfair I think our government is
responsible for the life lost when they
lie the same way you see people know
where your mass because I see the
American BP not wearing in the hospital
because American media is saying that
masses are useless and people inject
disimpact into their body because Donald
Trump says so so of course when the
government says says and does something
there's consequences at the beginning
you know you don't know how effective it
is if you are not sure you are going to
cause really huge panic and caused a lot
of loss and so later on while in January
funded and then you know the difficult
at is pretty bad and then you there two
days later they lock down the whole city
the other countries at that time only
have several cases and you now
understand everything of the virus that
people have you know many people style
and and many Santas work for you know
for a month you figure out that you have
all that information but the other
countries do not do anything and then
just let it spread I believe my country
has a more effective form of government
ah yah 3 when it talks about effective
my understanding of effects
effectiveness is that how effective you
achieve your goals I know that
Department has been a really bad issue
in the past and before the CCP took over
China you know people are having a
really bad life and my many the the
average what specifically what your
attire well so I'm talking about like
the 1940 and oh honey 78 to stuff got
pretty bad you know between 1957 and
1976 III used to think in a way - but
actually when I when I look at the data
of the average people's age increase
even even in that time the average
lifespan is has increased a lot you can
affected so 40 to 70 million people that
died during the Great Leap Forward by
some killer not bad and nobody Chinese
can I know what you said let me finish
this this fact it's important that the
the average lifespan was 35 years old
you know when the country was founded
and before the reform and when we opened
up the country
it was 68 already so I agree with you on
the fact that if we define effective at
getting what you're supposed to do done
I think the Chinese government from
basically 1980 up until 2013 i if it was
2013 I probably would have closed my
video the Singaporean Prime Minister or
whatever years ago lauded that said it
was so impressive that the Chinese
government had this ability to think in
the long term you know anybody that
studied economics you realize if you can
manage your country in the scope of the
long term of ten year periods you can
actually do a much better job with
managing
the country if you don't have to every
four years worry about getting reelected
and trying to convince voters that
because you believe in Jesus as your
Savior so you're a good person that you
know you can do a lot of better stuff
but after she deemed young took over I'm
not trying to say Xi Jinping is a bad
guy I'm not trying to say he's an evil
monster I'm just trying to say he's
clearly not cut out for the job
China has only gotten worse since he's
gotten office the GDP has gone down Xin
Jiang you have that you have Shang Gong
you have all these problems where you
know people the world is turning against
China the international society is
turning against China and Xi Jinping has
to accept responsibility for that
if you centralize the power you have to
accept the results of that you can't
like just blame all the fog to like one
guy I don't think like our Chairman is
the the only person who control
everything and given without you
everything like it's a whole system that
it's getting people to build a house
where though as to dr. Ahn is to like
all the community to check every person
go in a country go into the community so
it is the whole system that is working
it and what we are talking about is if
the system is efficient and I think like
just like if you're just talking about
the pandemic it is definitely very
efficient we all go back to our were
like normal you know you are you are
saying that she committed me China
government less effective so now you
guys is more effective so can I talk
about you know not just like we are
becoming worse but you know how you are
I think it's comparing [ __ ] to diarrhea
I think America is not very effective
and I think honestly I'm extremely
effective I mean I think they're both
bad if you change the word effective to
efficient now definitely say like
Chinese government's much more efficient
than the American one but my
understanding of the word effective is
not only getting things done yes the
Chinese government can get [ __ ] done
quickly immediately but that often means
unintentional like wounds and also many
of them are self-inflicted so if you
look at the long term
and where we're going I don't think
right now we are really having a very
effective government I mean the core
ideas like is a centralized government
more efficient than a decentralized one
right I mean I think there are many
things that America does you know over
the course of its history of time and
and how its government has been set up
maybe not in recent history but in the
long term where it has been more
effective but in certain instances we do
see China kind of advancing in a more
efficient ways than than others putting
too big of an umbrella on like which
government especially given the rapid
change changes in government that's
happened in the last you know four to
five years is kind of makes the question
a little bit hard to stand very rigidly
on one side or the other there are
strong reasons to believe that the virus
started in Wuhan lab
I personally believe Bill Gates and
Anthony Falchi have a huge hand in this
because they are very set on creating a
mandatory vaccine for the entire world
and a microchip that's going to put
everybody on a database which they are
incredibly vocal about I think that if
you look into it you can see that there
is a lot to be gained by Bill Gates and
the people who are he's associating with
the CDC the WHO which he funds by the
way there there there's a lot for him to
gain I think the only problem with that
product that I have is the word strong I
mean it could have come from the lab for
sure I wouldn't negate that but like
it's strong to me just makes me you know
the the idea that one lab would
deliberately design a virus like this
and leak it just to remove people's
freedom it's almost laughable because
you know like see see p-value stability
and economic development over everything
why would they do this to ourselves I
mean we are the first one to get hit
right just before this was happening you
were having some of the wildest protests
I ever saw in my life in the streets and
all of a sudden protesting became
illegal like that's I mean you can see
that as a coincidence but if you looked
at history we've seen tyrannical
governments go time and time again
trying to take away people's freedoms
and trick them into doing what is the
right thing for people's from pupil
safety and security at the end of the
day like all we have now is a stronger
media a stronger and more powerful media
that can manipulate people more easily
there's no reason to believe that
governments are gonna stop doing what
they did just because we live in the
current era whether this is a design
virus you know it's not up to us to
answer that we do have the knowledge but
we should listen to the experts who
understand virus and now if the
scientists say that this looks like a
design virus because it's just way too
hard almost a basically impossible for
human to design such virus I just I just
want to say I mean is that like the
least possible offensive way I feel you
guys are just so
trusting like somebody said before trust
the experts and it's like these experts
are the people who are owned by the
politicians that have everything to gain
by taking away your freedoms I think we
should clarify is the whole bill gates
is we they talked about using digital
certificates with health records which
is not the same as implanting microchips
in our brain to track our movement to do
all of that I mean if they really wanted
to do that there's much more efficacious
ways to do it
oh I translate and interpret for the
occasion and those were their their
foundation I think when he talks about
population control it's more about first
control as Malphite it's not like wiping
out half of the population by a pandemic
you know also like ten or twelve years
ago whenever the office was on NBC
Dwight Schrute did say that there's too
many people in this world and we need a
new pandemic so I don't know Rainn
Wilson guys we should investigate him
I'm willing to sacrifice my personal
freedom to combat the virus
I think the key award is how much
freedom right we we the people in trust
or government to make a decision to find
the balance between individual freedom
and safety right
so in circumstances like this in a
pandemic I'm willing to surrender some
of my freedom in exchange for more
safety same way like when I go on a
plane I'm I'm willing to to go through a
security check have people checking my
luggage or even the pat-down I know that
wasn't me that talks a lot about like
how draconian the Chinese measures has
been I think there's a double standard
here in the very beginning when Wuhan
was first going to lockdown I remember
very clearly I read on the news saying
that oh look at this dictatorship
they're putting people in hell but when
Italy went into lockdown the Western
media praised them for you know being
responsible for their people's safety so
this is really ridiculous do I agree
that sometimes the Chinese government's
doing too much to violate freedoms and
just to fight this pandemic I agree but
it's in the pandemic your freedom will
be sacrifice for sure unless you want to
like a zombie planet we give up our
freedoms in so many other ways just to
live in society right I mean it's like
like Rousseau says like we're born free
but we're everywhere in Chains because
that's that is the social contract that
is sort of like in order to exist in
society we need to be governed and
follow certain rules so if I were able
to save a life if I were able to if that
was on the line for me I I think my
notion or my sort of you know idea of
like freedom to give that up in exchange
for somebody's welfare I think for me is
something that I would personally be be
willing to give up
you guys know my stance at this point I
think freedom is incredibly important I
think that yes there are certain laws
that come into play yes we do sacrifice
certain certain things for the greater
good but at the end of the day at least
in America we have the Constitution and
we have very specific things that are
defended and we are seeing them trampled
on more and more as we go into this I
also am NOT speaking about my freedoms
it's not like oh like I don't get to do
this I don't get to do that it's not a
selfish motive it's I don't want to see
a precedent happens that justifies
taking away the world's freedoms that
brings the society into a collapse like
I'm it's like a bigger picture thing I
mean you can see it you can like in
China when I first went to China in 2009
again in 2011 and again in 2012 I could
talk to my professors about Tiananmen
Square I could talk to him about Tibet I
could talk to him about Taiwan I could
talk to about anything and you know what
they could criticize the government
openly if they wanted to that was how it
was and then over the last you know
seven years basically China has
progressively bit by bit given up little
freedoms that have now put it into an
age where it's much more similar to
North Korea and much less similar to
Singapore which it originally aspired
and was so close to being was because
not once you gave up your freedoms it
was bit by bit by bit the other side is
misinformed
I believe that anybody who doesn't see
this as a deliberate ploy to launch us
forward into the New World Order is
misinformed and hasn't done the proper
research that's my personal opinion
nothing against anybody I know we're all
doing our best but I think everybody
people are throwing like message to each
other as a weapon it's not I mean I need
you to know this this is that so we're
just using this as weapon to attack each
other and to be empowered for our side
coreos that we exist in a world where we
have a bias we have a strong point of
view we have these things and they're
reinforced by the media that we consume
and honestly I think that we don't
generally consume media that we don't
agree with we don't consume media that
we have a strong opinion against it's a
lot more for us just easier honestly to
just say all those people are
misinformed all those people are just
not or not woke they're not like this
they're not that and I think it's just a
lot easier for us to just go give give
me the information give me all the give
me all the data that backs up my point
of view because who wants to just go in
and look at the world as a thing that
it's like I'm gonna I'm gonna look up
[ __ ] that is that totally [ __ ] my
worldview and totally no challenges me
nobody that's gonna everyone me and make
me agitated and pissed off right exactly
it's like everyone's like everyone if
you do read it it's just to ridicule it
it's just to be like oh this is [ __ ]
I said I disagree because one my to say
that you guys are misinformed because I
myself might be very misinformed well my
experience living in Hong Kong the US
and other parts of the world really
changed my opinion about media because I
know how miss boom we can be like if I
only read American news I'll be too
scared to come back to China but the
same way if I only read Chinese news I
would never choose to study in the u.s.
so I think probably the truth kind of
lies in between I have learned something
from the other side
you
what comes to me the first is actually
how the lands of the western people via
China has depend not necessarily depend
but like it's very strong it's not
strengthened it's gotten much worse yeah
and actually some of the stuff is is not
accurately in the way that for example
that criticize absolute government Wow
in the pandemic there are many events
are because of society criticized the
government a lot like annually on the
reason why you know it because we
criticize it to get the government and
what's kind of ban is trying to dis
invalidate the legitimacy of CCP you
know that's okay right now on way bla
post a picture of Winnie the Pooh and
say I think it looks like Winnie the
Pooh you're trying to say the Communist
Party only gets upset when you question
their legitimacy guess what you were
right 10 years ago not anymore
because now you have a leader that bans
Winnie the Pooh the prompters I have
learned something from the other side so
if you want we can restart if you
disagree you can be honest and turning
off your camera but if you agree please
talk about what you have learned from
the other side I think what I've learned
honestly just even in this conversation
that seemed like it was kind of Dee
railing is that how much culture and
where we come from and how we're brought
up really affects the lens in which we
we view things that we look in very
monolithic terms you know like ideas
like freedom like truth I think for me
what I've learned is like going for it
to view that in a way to not just read
something like they're taking this away
from me or everybody's that's fake news
this is that it's more just like looking
at it sort of as a spectrum instead of
you know just very rigid or binary
things there's a lot of things that I'm
sure Luna and I agree on and then
there's a lot of things that we probably
would harshly just really disagree on
and the fact that that can exist that we
can have parts of our mind and our the
way that we view the world that are so
similar but then
their parts that we just like completely
disagree on just goes to show you that
there's so many different shades of
human psychology and to me I think
that's the interest of life I think that
that is it that's why I like this idea
of this show middle ground I know the
idea of thinking and extremes makes the
world simple yes or no right or wrong
you're with us or you're against us but
that is oversimplifying a world that is
much more complicated than that in the
world
beauty is in those details actually I
don't think this other side because for
example I disagree with my sites too so
you know it's not found like China
versus us all right I agree with many
points of each and every one of you and
disagree on many points as well so I
don't really see it as this bipolar
debate for example I love Melanie's
great um passion about freedom like
actually in China we need more people to
root for freedom because we have too
many people rooting for the
establishment already we could have
become friends and keep communicating
with each other down dude I got videos
all over that thing that talk about
subjects that you would definitely be
interested